>>'V BRAVERY AND HONOR
WILL CASSIDY F RE
T 6D 70-YEAR-OLD MEN WHO HIDE
E  NIVE
AN.
CK WITPUCONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHAIN.
CONGRESSWON, WE JUST HEARD YOU
NGTHE LAST
MEY
OF THE FEMALE WITNESSES O
YOU CALLED THEIN ANDEN,
ESE BRAVID
SPALKINGUT
AND WHY DO YOU THI YBRAVER?EL IN
TREMENDOUSLY M
INSPIRATIONAL, NOT JUST FOR ,
R MEALLY ALLRO MEN, TOO,TO SEEHY
SHAYE
RUBY FREE MAN AND LY WHO
COMMITTEE -- CSIN RING A TRUN R
MEADOWS,HE EXTENT TO
NOT ST YOUE
N'HOHERS THA
D THEY DTEND YOUNGER, O THE
WHAT
HAPPENEDANN AGAIWILLING
STEPRD PATRIOTIC
A TREMENDOUSESSON FOL
ESESE  DAUGHTERS W THE
WOE F E E.UGR SION
T THEMSE W ORIOTISAN
SSY HUTCHINSON
HEARING,  AND O
THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN CTER ACT A
MATTHEWS AS LI PAI ABOUT
THE OTHER WITNESS RIGHT NEXT TOT
ES FOCUSING THEIR CKS MORE OE W
VICIOU THINK THA WEE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS IS REALL
SG
PRESIDENT WHO  MOBE KNEWMED TO
OM
Y W
REPUBLICANS INSE E
OU TRSTAND HAPPEI THPE WHO
I THINK, OUR
REAL H
ALL OF UTAP BACK
SA LOOK, THENORMAL SOR VIT, TOXP
THE ADE RE
REPUBLICANS IN THE H NBEACCOUNR
ACTIONS, AND THEY NEED T
S IO
A BUNCHTH LEADERS ARETRYING TOS
CO THAT IVN THHEARINGS EXPRESSIN
OUTRAGE AT THEIRORMER
LIES, BI STEPIEND N
SPPE
YO
WH, SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE YOU'RE STAND
WYN EVERY VOTE ABOUT IVATELY.EA
SAISINTO.
I'M NOGO THING
AREN'T TRUE ABOUT THELECTION.
PURPOSE OF
GEIN HAVE TOOSE N MAINTAINING A
HE CONSTITUTIONAL  ANDG THE
AM THE TRUTH , I'M GOING TO
AUGUST 17th AND CO TO OIN MATTEP
HAO ENSURE DONALD
E CLOSE TO
F YOYOUR JOBS BECAUSE OF YOURK
ON THIAVORTH IT  YOU? THERE'SLI
COMMITTEE ISSTPORTANT THING I'VN
TAKE AN  THAT WE SWEARNDGOD TO
ASANS DONALDMP
ON THISTO ENSE TH W E WHAT HAPD
SOWE CST
LEGISLIOTI HELP ENSURE IT NEVER
>> YOU'VULD ENE YO FPRESIDENT TP
LE PART?
>> I HAVEN'TLLT
POINT I HAVE NOTE CISION
WY A CI WEE TO DO ON TELITTEE, L
TOWARDS THE DO T WOK
IAID, I BELIEVE
REALLY TNKY SERIOUSLABOU
WE'VE TOE WHLLTAKE TIRBL T
OATHRID WH ALITF THESHAVE
VE
STS F  AND
POLITICST WE HAVE LIVED
THROUGH OVER THE LASAR AND CERT
ABOUT A VOTE TT STU
WERENE OSE CODIFY E
MAGE, A
LME .
YOU USEDPOSEINFAMOUSLY LED TO
OPPOSITION TEN YEARSEX MARRIAGEN
LOY ER VERR FAMIER, AN
GIVEN
THE ADDITIALLD BE  T SUGIONTHTI
JUSTICE OM' OPANS THAT WAND MAK.
I WOULD URGMYN UES ID T